my takeaways from having built a couple
of fun things with node and that's what
I want to talk about today are if you
want to learn or refresh your skills in
JavaScript you should make a game with
no js' and if you're a JavaScript
developer already you should teach
others how to make a game with no Jess
that's what I'm gonna kind of argue
today and we can talk a little bit about
why that is so I want to share with you
two projects that I built this year the
first one is called deal with it bot and
what this spot does is it actually
recognizes faces in a user-supplied
photo and automatically slides pixelated
shades on every face in the photo up to
64 simultaneous faces which is hilarious
for a group photo family reunion whatnot
and I know this meme is like old enough
to be retro which but anyway so this is
the thing I built earlier this year it's
essentially a node app that runs in the
browser it uses the cognitive services
face API for facial recognition Express
socket IO and CSS animations powered by
JavaScript and math right just figure
out where those glasses go figure out
how they should be scaled and skewed and
all of that so let me kind of break down
exactly how that works essentially in
this in this web app the user has a
photo a URL for photo and supplies that
in a text box and hits click you know
clicks button and that gets delivered to
cognitive services face API if you
haven't tried this yet Microsoft
releases family of api's under the
cognitive services umbrella they're very
cool like I think almost all of them
have a free tier which is what I'm using
for this web app and basically the whole
idea of cognitive services api is they
take these really common machine
learning scenarios like recommendation
engines and object recognition and
facial recognition and says instead of
you having to like instead of all of us
having to build that machine learning
model over and over and over because
it's essentially like the same model
that we're building why don't what if
Microsoft built that model and then we
could just use it as a REST API right
and so that's what that's the idea of
this thing is like I don't have to build
a facial recognition model I just send
of
literally send a photo to this API it
returns back JSON JSON object of all the
faces all of the like in this case
coordinates for the eyes eyebrows nose
mouth right and that's really cool
because I didn't have to build it so I
could focus on doing something that was
more fun so essentially I get back this
JSON return and it tells me these
coordinates for every face in the
picture so we have all these data points
and after doing some math we shuttle a
couple of numbers from the server back
to the browser so right we have this
image we sent that image over socket IO
to the brow to the server the server
does some stuff it does some number
crunching it sends a couple of values
back to the browser and then we use
these numbers to for every face create a
div with an SVG inside of it and that
SVG is this one you see here and we
apply various scalars and rotations to
it so that it actually matches the face
right if the face is turned if the face
is like this if the piece is small or
big it's actually going to adapt to that
one thing that's what was really
interesting about developing this
actually is um you know when you get
these coordinates back their absolute
which means if you have a 200 pixel wide
image it's going to give you back you
know
okay the eye is at 100 so what happens
if you have a really big image and you
need to scale it down in the browser you
need to scale down all those coordinates
as well so that was one kind of
interesting challenge with doing this in
the browser you obviously you don't want
an image that's 3,000 pixels wide to
learn the browser and the glasses come
down and they're so far off the screen
that you didn't even see that happen
right so there's a little bit of math
that happens here it's nothing too
terribly scary but we take that ret you
know so once we've kind of positioned
the glasses and we know where they need
to fall then we basically translate that
upward off the top of the browser and
slowly animate them down with the CSS
animation and then we kind of show the
deal with it text at the bottom so
here's the whole thing in action I just
grabbed a picture from friends
it's also really good with Golden Girls
I've done the cast of Seinfeld you can
see that these glasses all land at the
same time and it's not as noticeable
here but when you have let's say a face
near the top of the screen and a face at
the bottom you'll notice the one at the
bottom the glasses move faster so that
they all land at the exact same time
which is a really cool effect in this
case where the eyes are all pretty much
in the same plane that effect isn't as
dramatic so I was cheap when I made this
and I didn't want to save these images
on my own server because I didn't want
to pay for it so if you notice the URL
for the image is actually just hashed
into the URL for the page oh you can't
see it it's kind of very very light but
I actually don't I don't save any of the
images so you put that that URL in and
if you want to share this out like
there's a share on Twitter button it
actually is just like a iPhone clubhead
your website's not net slash and then
the hash of the URL that the person put
in so that was just my way of being
cheap because I didn't want to save all
of these photos to some like blob
storage or something like that right so
this was my first kind of project that I
was kind of playing around this idea of
of fun applications for nodejs
it's really simple I love it because
there's a small scope it's not really
that complicated it's one of those
things where the idea is more valuable
than the code like I mean the code isn't
really that complicated right I I wrote
this on a four hour bus ride from Dallas
to Austin most of it at least so it's
just it's not perfect right it goes a
little haywire on iphone but you know it
gets the idea across it's really well
scoped and it's just kind of funny
people
people love to putting their own photos
and whatever if you want to check this
out actually the whole thing is
open-source
you can see the bottom it's the source
on github I'm gonna have a link to all
of that at the end so don't worry about
taking notes for that I have a I have
one master link that has all of my
resources I'll be talking about today
so after I made the deal with it bought
I decided to take
on something a little bit more ambitious
and that was connectedness so
connectedness is a Wi-Fi modem
peripheral for the original NES console
and I also wrote a Twitter stream client
in assembly language that will run on an
NES cartridge what's that it is a big
difference yeah Java JavaScript -
assembly is like wait memory mapping
compiling what is yeah so so this is
essentially a project that's composed of
three parts and oh you can see it here
working actually
so I sent a tweet the the client is
looking for a hashtag in this case
connected NES hashtag and then it's
streaming that to the NES there's not a
computer connected to this the console
is not hacked in any way it is a
standard issue console no modifications
to it the Wi-Fi modem actually plugs
into the second controller port so is a
perfectly stock situation you can take
and plug it into another console work
totally fine and it's composed of kind
of three parts which I want to talk
about a little bit more in detail so
first of all there's a custom cloud
hosted server back-end and that's the
node part of this secondly the actual
hardware the wireless modem now it's not
really a modem I call it a wireless
modem because I think that is very
understandable to people and I also like
that idea of like a false history like
Oh remember when the NES had like a
wireless modem and you're like maybe it
could have been a thing I really love
projects that play with people's
perceptions of history so no it's not
technically a modem
it's a microcontroller that has Wi-Fi
capabilities and we'll talk about that
in a second but then the third part of
this is NES game cartridge with the
custom ROM so what kind of walkthrough
how that worked and I should say you
know as I mentioned before I've been
making old games mostly for the NES for
about six or seven years so I did not
like learn
nes development for this project the NES
like assembly language is actually the
easiest part of this for me just because
I've been doing it for years so it
wasn't like I just was like oh just like
learn this really complicated thing one
day and just make this little project in
two weeks I did make this in two weeks
but it was it was only after years and
years of writing assembly language so I
I always want to like emphasize that you
know things that seem effortless are not
effortless right there's like years of
preparation and work and practice and
experience that go into that and I think
is sort of disingenuous to be like oh
yeah I just made it in two weeks even
though I did you know I did but but
again there's a lot of a lot of really
hard it was it was a it was a difficult
journey to get there right so let's talk
a little bit more about these components
so the back end is a node app
essentially what it's doing is I have a
twit node module which is grabbing the
latest tweet about connectedness or I
can change it to any any hashtag I want
from Twitter streaming API it parses a
tweet into a single string and it
publishes that string to the cloud so
it's kind of interesting so unlike most
applications where we're like I will say
we're writing a note app for the web
browser
we want it to be responsive right cuz
it's the web the NES is not responsive
and it's also not smart and so going
against best practice for how we develop
with JavaScript I tried to put in a lot
of upfront processing in this case I
take a tweet I turn it into a single
string or you know it returns back
something that I can basically work work
with as a string I actually go ahead and
figure out the line breaks and I pad it
with spacing and okay 24 characters
slice I have to do some kind of
interesting things to figure out word
breaks because I know exactly how many
pixels I can display on the NES and it's
256 across
some very very very constrained it's
like the opposite of responsive web
design I know exactly what this display
is going to look like even a giant TV
it's just going to scale up those pixels
so we get our we get our tweets that are
based on this hashtag they're a person
of a single string I take out things
like emoji because with the NES you've
got 256 tiles that you can use this
letters which means you would burn
through emoji you know you could use up
your whole tile set with just like a
quarter of the possible emoji so I made
the artistic decision to change all
emoji into question marks just so I can
actually fit I need to fit all the
alphanumeric characters right so after
we've taken this string and got it
exactly how we want it we need to
actually get it to the NES which does
not have internet capabilities that we
can give give it internet capabilities
so this is a particle photon has anyone
here used two photon I love the photon
so it is Arduino like Arduino compatible
micro controller it has onboard Wi-Fi
it's like 9 bucks and it has I think
it's about about that or it's it's
really inexpensive and it also has a
cloud-based IDE so I can actually
reflash it over the web so I could be
here and push some new code and as long
as my particle photon is on Wi-Fi at
home it will actually reflash over the
web which is super super awesome so this
is what I use for the wireless modem so
particle who makes this board they have
actually created a JavaScript API for
sending small amounts of data so they
take care of that which is great and
they publish a node app they also have
like a regular sort of JavaScript
library that you can include in a web
page and you can publish you can wait
for events you can publish events things
like that so I can basically send that
string over as an event and this device
is listening for that really all the
microcontroller does after it receives
that string is convert the string into
an array of bytes because now we're
getting ready to go into end
yes land and a string is not going to be
something that NES can understand it's
gonna be sending bytes one byte at a
time and it's actually doing it through
the controller port so how does that
work well if you think about it you know
the NES is the NES controller every time
you press a button it's just sending
some bytes right and so if you sent a
lot of bytes through that controller
port you could send data right and
that's exactly what I do this is a
picture of me desoldering the wires so
this is actually what if you took an NES
controller and opened it up this is what
you'd see on the inside I'm desoldering
the wires from the board because these
wires are very thin and they have leads
on connecting them to the board and I
want to get those leads because if I try
to work with the wires they're just
gonna fray and anger me
I know because that's what I did the
first time so these little wires you
have power ground data clock latch and
you can actually you know use this
microcontroller to you hook up all these
wires to different pins on the photon
just like you would with an Arduino or
something like that and you actually
just send those bytes and you fold the
NES into thinking that it's a controller
so if you think about an NES controller
it has eight buttons a B select start up
down left right
it's an 8-bit game console that is not a
coincidence that it has eight buttons
people know the Konami code right up up
down left right so it's it's it's from
these I like to rearrange these like
stellar bods this is like my greatest
anagram moment ever when I realized that
that was stellar bods especially you
know it's a modem it's great okay so
essentially we take we kind of hijack
this system and deliver the bytes this
way someone very smartly asked me once
what happens if you just plug in a
regular controller and like press the
buttons it will just print garbage texts
as you would expect
each button is checked in serial one at
a time so these are some examples of you
know things you might send over as
button presses you just hike hijack
those and they're corresponding to the
ANSI values for each of the letters so I
did something kind of goofy which was
like okay so the NES doesn't have a
built in font set ok so unlike early
computers that had you know a built in
set of letters where you can do like
hello world and something would show up
the NES doesn't have any built-in
graphics text anything like that so I
had to draw those by hand into memory
and I decided to put the letters
corresponding to their ANSI hex values
so instead of making a lookup table is
just literally pulling them directly
from RAM it's kind of cool this is the
first model that I made in this really
lovely kind of cross stitched cosy I'm
really like I really like the crafty and
cute aesthetic so there's actually just
like a little quarter sized breadboard
in there with a particle photon and you
can see like it blinks and then the
whole thing lights up and it's very cute
this is version 2 which is made with
laser-cut acrylic this is nice as you
actually see the board inside and it
lights up and it's a little more like
mystical but it's the same idea so we've
talked about the server we talked about
the the back end and we talked about the
photon let's talk a little bit about the
nes code so this is a ROM you'll see
here it says tweet hashtag ask on at the
bottom because actually debuted this at
OSCON in Austin which was really really
super fun so as I mentioned before again
everything done by hand so all the
graphics all the text needs to be
written into these files by hand some
people ask me how do you make an NES
game like what what is the toolset for
that and the answer is that you know
Nintendo didn't release developer tools
widely and so everything that we have
today for those of us in the homebrew
community is all community made tools so
we don't actually know how old NES games
were made the process is probably very
similar
to what came out of the community these
community based tools so we have you
know 6502 compiler we have like a
software that will help us do graphic
tiles and arrange them and things like
that and we have other than that though
I mean you're just writing it a notepad
and compile it and it's a ROM you can
create these cartridges by taking the
ROM now that this ROM would work in an
emulator the issue is that the hardware
doesn't plug in because I don't have an
NES port on my computer but essentially
you take that ROM cut it in half divide
it up onto two eeproms I get out my
little EEPROM burner which I think has a
serial cable I don't it's an ancient
device burn those two eeproms
solder them onto a cartridge and there
you go
fortunately there are more contemporary
ways to do that there's things like
cartridges that have a compact flash
card or an SD card so you can just throw
the ramens on there you don't have to
get out your soldering iron and that's
incredibly helpful if anyone's
interested what assembly looks like here
some so this code what this code does is
you noticed before those they're the
balloons that fly up on the screen what
this code does is it um when a balloon
reaches the top of the screen and it's
like kind of off the screen it creates a
new place to spawn at the bottom this is
part of the code that does that for one
balloon so this this code is basically
resetting the sprite position for one
balloon and this isn't all of it so what
is this like it's it's tens of lines so
you can imagine of course the lines very
short they do one specific thing like
put a number here add this number to it
but it assembly can get quite long so
you can get easily get a couple thousand
lines for something really really simple
so that's pretty straightforward I feel
like it's easy I don't know it's not
easy it's easy when you talk about it
when it's already done of course there
are all sorts of challenges things like
optimizing line break
so something that I hadn't ever had to
think about before because you would
never ever try to like manually put line
breaks into running text and JavaScript
like it kind of makes you go don't do
that but it was really necessary in this
case so thinking about like how to what
do you do when someone tweets oh my god
and it's more than 24 characters right
how do you decide like where to break
unpredictable things or what happens
when you run out of lines right if the
TV becomes full how does an NES
controller work it was actually a
non-trivial question it was something
really important to understand I
actually wrote a game that its sole
purpose was to translate the bytes that
were coming over because it was so so
odd that I couldn't even really debug it
I had to create a new game that actually
printed the bytes on the screen so I
could help debug my own software
super-weird this is another one I never
thought about how do you make a
JavaScript application for something
that has no browser-based user interface
so if you think about a node server
let's say you go to a website and the
website like oh there's a user here I
better go wake up that node server okay
in this case there's no browser so
there's nothing waking up the node
server the node server needs to be
running all of the time and so that was
kind of an interesting concept to me
because I had never had to think about
that right this note server needs to be
on all the time I ended up deploying it
to Azure and setting it to be like
there's a setting called always-on so it
doesn't go to sleep even if it hasn't
been active for years it's gonna stay on
all the time so that when that tweet
comes in that matches matches your
hashtag it's ready to process that so a
confession is that these are my first
two no js' projects ever I'm relatively
new to node even though I've been kind
of playing with web front-end
development since I was about 14 when I
got my first or we got our first family
computer I didn't really get into node
that much until this year so I'm fairly
new and I kind of want to talk about the
experience of doing these two projects
which were really propelled even though
they were difficult
propelled by the fact that they were fun
fun not just for fun anymore
I have a couple of thoughts about why
fun is important and and why fun helped
propel me through these through these
projects a fun project for a beginner a
fun project is one that you're going to
keep coming back to even when you hit
difficulties if I had decided to teach
myself node by creating something that
updates interest rates in a sequel
database and then I like ran into some
problem I'd be like well that's fine I
don't really care about that anyway but
a fun project is what kind of gets you
because you're just like I have to
figure this out I want the glasses to
slide perfectly right when you get
invested in your own learning in that
way it really helps you to overcome
those bumps that you're going to
inevitably hit I also believe very
strongly that when it comes to teaching
and learning something like node
tutorials that are about building
something fun help break down the
intimidation factor I don't know about
y'all but I get intimidated when I go to
a tutorial and it's like use throwing
around all these words I don't know and
it's like oh it's so easy and then I
know that I can't understand it right
maybe you've had that experience as well
so when tutorials are based on something
that's fun it it kind of changes the
atmosphere and people who are new to
coding say oh like programmers like
funny stuff like I do like they like
cats and memes and and it helps you feel
like oh this is someone I have something
in common with especially people that
maybe haven't been encouraged to try
programming or maybe feel like they
don't fit in or they don't fit the
stereotype or something like that things
that are kind of fun and playful can
actually be the reason that someone
pushes on finally you could actually use
fun and playfulness to make serious
critiques right maybe you have a message
that you want to share and it's boring
to just say it outright but you can use
a sort of fun and play to talk about
more serious issues video games do this
time right I won't name any names but
I'm sure you didn't think of video games
that like they were fun and then you
realized oh my gosh this is a metaphor
for whatever and you have that moment
you're like whoa that's cool and maybe
it's about history or war or something
you would have never picked up a book on
but you actually had this really like
cool experience with and so I like I
like that aspect so for example I built
connectedness in part because when I was
a kid I didn't have an NES and I was I
was pretty girly and I didn't really
like games about sports and shooting
people and fighting and stuff like that
and so I never really pursued it and so
my entry into NES development was sort
of a way to recuperate this childhood
that I never had and to make it kind of
more girly and cutesy which is something
that if I had had when I was a kid I
might have been more interested in games
I might have been more interested in
coding and so there's some commentary
here on like gender stereotypes and
stuff right and I could write some like
stuffy academic paper about feminist
critical design approaches to video game
history which in fact I did as my
master's thesis in 2014 a feminist
critical design approach to video game
histories but like it turns out that
like not everybody wants to read a 70
page master's thesis actually this
number seems kind of high to me but like
last month every other day somebody read
this which seems like a a mistake
actually
I fear unaware a train right so not
everyone wants to read a 70 page tome
about feminist theory and video game
history but you can use fun and
playfulness to kind of I don't know just
like think about it without really
coming out and saying like here are all
the facts and here's all the theoretical
stuff that you need to think about I
don't think that's always effective
especially if you're talking to people
that may not agree with you yet right if
you're trying to convince somebody you
don't want to give them all the turns
there are terms that are gonna shut
their ears off right so playfulness and
fun can be a way to sort of bridge those
communication gaps like sometimes we're
on the same page we're just not using
the same words so I think playfulness
and fun have a real
interesting way of bridging those
disconnects so this is why I think you
should make simple games and fun stuff
with no Jess or teach games with no Jess
I think scope is really key one thing I
worry about with with respect to know
Jess is whether new coders who are
coming in
we'll try JavaScript and whether they'll
stick with it like for me when I learned
about node.js I was like Oh JavaScript
that thing where you can make alert
dialog boxes that actually does
something else that's cool because I was
thinking about the 90s in the old school
like cut and paste like make a guest
book counter stuff that does not exist
anymore but you know what about those
people who don't have any coding
experience are they gonna choose
JavaScript and are they gonna choose it
over something like Swift or Python in
particular I think one thing that Swift
and Python do really well is onboarding
folks that are completely new to
programming right so things like this if
if you haven't read automate the boring
stuff with Python or if someone's like
hey I want to get into coding what
should I do one thing that's really
great about this book is it is so so
beautifully geared toward a beginner
talking about things like hey your codes
gonna be ugly and that's fine we're
gonna go fix it later really stepping
you through like hey it's this is a
thing called terminal let's talk about
that right and I think this is part of
the reason that we see so much success
with these languages with young people
in school
we might have this idea that like Oh
young people are great at computers and
and they are and they're very smart but
my experience when I was teaching
undergraduates at University of Texas
was that many of my students had never
used an SD card or they had never used a
USB device if you think about when the
iPhone came out of college freshmen was
like 10 or 11 the only computing device
they may have ever used as an iPad and
so they're coming from a different
perspective than those of us who have
been around even a little bit longer
right
how many workshops I've gone to where
students are getting hung up on terminal
like they didn't
CD into the directory that they just
made and that's like a totally
understandable thing and we often leave
that step out of instructions like oh
you have to do this thing called CD like
there's actually a folder structure and
I had students who actually had
difficulty even with the concept of a
folder structure again because of their
use of iPhone iPad where they're not
necessarily thinking about a folder
structure so um you know I always wonder
like how many node read Me's start with
like oh this is so easy just in humans
still above the blah and how many people
go to terminal and they do NPM install
both alot it says NPM is not a known
command and they're like oh well I guess
I'm bad at computers goodbye forever oh
there's like a log off right uh and I
think sometimes like developers we have
this idea of like well look programming
stuff kid like if you can't figure this
out then you know you'll never make it
in this town which i think is a huge
disservice actually and one thing we
need to think about is actually a lot of
people who come to coding are basically
like one bad experience away from going
like no never mind right especially
people you know like my experience was
that people were always discouraging me
from using computers when I was a kid
you know in the late 90s early 2000s it
was like oh you better watch out there's
weirdos on the internet and like you
know there was this panic I think one
that still exists today but maybe in the
terms of like oh man Twitter's yes big
garbage fire you should just log off and
so so sometimes people are already
discouraged when they come to us to
learn how to code and I don't think we
should turn our backs on them I think we
owe it to them to like help them have a
good experience and part of that is I
think defusing some of the tension and I
think we can do that with fun
so I like to think of no GS as an
elevator
perched halfway up a mountainside it
makes things really convenient for
people who have already climbed Mount
JavaScript part of the way but if you're
new how do you get there right so I
guess I would just end by saying if
you're new to programming
javascript or node and you're like here
to check it out welcome there is an
elevator it's like up there you can't
reach it now it's solely fine but if
you're passionate about helping others
learn javascript or node I think we have
sort of an obligation to make that ride
really fun right so we don't we should
not be making trail maps we should be
making zip lines and ski lifts with
disco lights and rave music and we
should be setting up games of
hide-and-seek that get us up the
mountain without us even realizing it
right let's make that journey fun so if
you want to check out any of the
projects have done everything I talked
about today was open source a lot of my
colleagues have also done really cool
fun and games themed stuff with with
node and have created tutorials as well
this is a link to a blog post on my
website and I want to actually continue
to add things to this so maybe bookmark
it come back in a week and maybe I'll
have some more stuff up there these are
some things that I've kind of tried out
I think are cool I think I have a lot of
potential you can see how people are
starting to try to reach out and teach
node and JavaScript to folks that are
starting out but I think there's a huge
room for us to do more in that space so
that's pretty much it if you make
something with nodejs and make it make a
game or you have some ideas I'd love to
hear it
you can talk to me I'm gonna be the
Micra see Microsoft booth or I'll be
around or you can find me on Twitter
my there's my handle if you do the
Twitter thing and that's it thank you so
very much